has what has been the uh most
uncomfortable role you've played as a uh
as someone who acts because I do feel
like
there's a there's a lot that comes with
that gig you know you got to kind of die
I think Antebellum was tough yeah I
don't know if I'll ever do a role like
that again it was really tough to go and
be on a plantation and
you know play an enslaved person in
modern day times it was a lot on see
that seems deep it seems heavy yeah it
was very heavy and it took a lot for me
to get that off of me too because
immediately after I wrapped my friends
were like let's go to Mexico and so I
was like well I need a vacation but I
couldn't shake that role and I would
just remember showing up
just like being super uneasy I'm like
girl what the [__] is wrong with you and
I'm like listen I lived basically lived
on the plantation for two months you
know I did it for my reasons to chant to
honor you know my ancestors and to bring
awareness
um you know to to a lot of injustices
but yeah I don't think I think that was
probably my hardest so when they say
like when you act you can like get into
the role I just saw
um uh the guy who plays Franklin State
on snowfall say he like channeled the
devil to be Franklin Saint in snowfall
and he's like it like it messed with him
like after the show was over a little
bit yeah people don't realize you're
you're living and breathing and I always
you know stay out into the universe like
reduce Janelle Monae I want you to see
the spirit of this character and and uh
yeah a lot a lot a lot of times it's
hard to shake those rows off uh somebody
who you had as a mentor which not a lot
of people can say is uh you rest in
peace to prince prince who's one of the
greatest creators of all time quite
possibly the most talented musician ever
he's up there in terms of the guitar he
could do it all how did you guys
initially connect well he
um is always the story just still freaks
me out and that freaks me out but just I
can't even believe
that it happened but he was supposed to
show up I was open opening up for
Raphael Saadiq this is yeah exactly my
first album in um
I get a knock after I get finished
performing and
you know I had this I remember I had a
sinus infection that day I was just like
loopy and this uh really really pretty
girl knocks on the door and she was like
I have somebody who wants to talk to you
and the girl was DJ Rashida who was
Princess DJ at the time but I didn't
know that that was right you know his DJ
and she just gives me the phone and then
I'm like hello and I'm like congested
and just like hello and he's like hello
Janelle
did you know right away and I'm like hi
who is this
is Prince
Prince
yeah Prince I was supposed to come to
your gig but they gave me the wrong time
and I'm like
what like just freaking out or trying
not to because I don't want to embarrass
myself and so then he proceeds to say
listen I was supposed to come we're
having a jam session you know do you and
the band want to come back and you know
jam and I was like yeah we want to come
back and jam and
the rest was history the rest was this
on the Minneapolis no he was in L.A oh
so what he would do is and he was one of
the best like party throwers that you
will ever know I mean we have seen uh
some Chappelle skits that I mean I don't
know how true those kids are right but
my interactions with him have always
been like
can play guitar and party like
till the sun comes up seven in the
morning I didn't leave that night me and
my band we did not leave till seven in
the morning so this was a jam session
that didn't end until oh wow seven in
the morning it was it was just it was
amazing and he was just talking to me he
was like he was telling me everything he
loved about what he had seen me do and I
was like
I didn't even know you looked on the
internet right like you know who I am
that's wild I'm just like I would just
think you would be somewhere
yeah in in some sort of Castle right you
know with no Wi-Fi right with no Wi-Fi
but he was very aware and I always tell
people the best thing about him is like
even though he was mysterious he never
let his mystery get in the way of his
mentorship he was always like
wanting to give advice and you know open
up if you have any questions about the
business and didn't even charge me
anything to be on my album give me the
most about you have three pretty serious
mentors Prince Puff Daddy Big Boy give
me three lessons each of them
wow um
Prince is like obviously like the
blueprint for
um
you know owning your you know
like as an artist not being afraid to
fight for what you were old on the
business side of things right
um and also creating a blueprint
um
that felt so free and
you could do anything you know and just
and just also speaking with him
he just always reminded me that
musically there was nothing that I could
not do
and I think with puff
who has been a person of his word
um you know we have a partnership
together when he had first heard me and
doing the science fiction singing about
that and you know
doing doing whatever I wanted to do as
an artist creatively he always said like
I don't want to mess that up right I
just want the rest of the world to see
what I saw what I just saw tonight I
just want to help so I called him at a
really good time and
um you know he's just always been an
advocate for for me if I need to have
like
any business conversations I can I know
I can call him and you know listen to
him as well and then he just taught me
to just like be a fan of your own [__]
too you know promote your stuff if you
love it you got to promote your [__]
yeah yeah you worked hard and I think
with big boy big boy was just I mean I
got to give it to him you know the
reason why puffy even knew about me was
because of the work
that big boy gave to me I was thinking
back up I was also on Idlewild you know
he was really really promoting me with
purple ribbon he taught me the
importance of I think staying with
family like staying with the people
for like a little little bit Yeah my lip
but I always had my label but I would do
Partnerships it was like purple ribbon
yeah it was you was it was a Bubba spark
yes
[Laughter]
look at you a lot of people do not
remember killing my killer
Mike's new album which is coming out is
it that one is it it's not out yet okay
I listened to it a couple weeks ago okay
it's incredible one of the greatest
rappers of all time oh I gotta I gotta
listen to it yeah it's incredible